bist du bereit für y2q nein das ist
nicht der neueste Star Wars Roboter y2q
steht für years to Quantum und könnte
einen großen Einfluss auf unsere
digitale Welt haben wenn wir heute
Informationen übers Internet weitergeben
so wie auch jetzt gerade dann passiert
das verschlüsselt diese Verschlüsselung
basiert auf mathematischen Problemen wie
der primzahlzerlegung die aber kein
Problem für entsprechende
quantenalgorithmen sind es läuft also
auf einen Wettlauf hinaus was passiert
zuerst entsteht ein Quantencomputer der
groß genug ist um aktuelle
schlüsselungen zu knacken oder wird ein
neuer Algorithmus entwickelt der sicher
vor Quantencomputern ist y2q ist der
Countdown bis zu diesem Tag an dem
Quantencomputer leistungsfähig genug
sind um unsere Verschlüsselungen alle zu
knacken wann das ist das weiß niemand
aber es gibt Befürchtungen dass Hacker
nach dem Prinzip harvest now Crack later
arbeiten also heute schon sensible Daten
abgreifen die sie erst in mehreren
Jahren dann knacken werden können also
noch ein Grund sich schon heute zu
fragen